[Music]
kids will be heading back to school in
the next couple of weeks but those under
17 are the least
vaccinated of any eligible age group in
this country close to 60 percent of 12
to 17 year olds
are unvaccinated and coveted
hospitalizations for five to 17 year
olds have jumped
at least 84 percent since mid-june
some teenagers now though are taking it
upon themselves to encourage their age
group to get
vaccinated adriana diaz shows how they
are debunking some of the biggest false
vaccine rumors that continuously pop up
on social media
[Music]
there's a good reason these school
principles
[Music]
are on the plank
[Music]
[Applause]
this block party with the dj funnel
cakes
and free backpacks is actually a
philadelphia school district
vaccination event targeting students 12
and up
before they go back to school and they
enlisted a special group to help
the philly teen vacs ambassadors 2017s
who volunteered through the school
district
to educate their peers about the vaccine
one member is 17-year-old anjali kiyosan
whose whole
family got coveted there's a lot of
false information out there
especially with social media being
around and we're there to spread real
information
let them know what's up let them know
what's up
what's your tagline we provide the facts
so you can get them
the ambassadors including 17-year-old
karen abraham
and 13 year old devon hester organize
events
and if you know anyone canvas
neighborhoods johnson and jasmine
jackson and johnson and on social media
get the vaccine to help the community
get the vaccine to help her community
[Music]
the main ones we've definitely heard
were the magnet one which was very
popular on tick tock
basically it's like you get the vaccine
and you can stick the magnet to where
you got your shot
and that's obviously not true not at all
what else are you hearing
i've heard people say that they're
turning into zombies which not true
what like the alternating of like dna
kind of thing
that's where i come in and tell them
what's actually in the vaccine
so mrna lipids
salts and sugars and everything you're
hearing online
isn't true we got teenagers here
they registering to be vaccinated the
resistance
is real most teens we spoke to here were
hesitant
until now you guys are all siblings
you're all here to get vaccinated
did you always want to get vaccinated no
at first i didn't want to get it because
i didn't trust it
you know a lot of theories with the
government and stuff like that but i've
seen
people get it and you know never find so
i'm okay with getting it now
dr sage myers runs community
vaccinations for the children's hospital
of philadelphia
a partner of this event i think that
teenagers like everyone else have seen
all of the sort of memes that have gone
on and the videos and sometimes they're
just a little afraid in general of
getting a shot that's one of the reasons
the philly team's ambassadors have been
amazing and just having that pierre with
them
has really made a huge difference every
single day public health officials are
on tv
does that have any impact on teens you
think
no because some teens follow after their
parents
and their parents think that the system
doesn't always work and that they're
testing us
unless it's a teen on there that's just
talking about the vaccine
i don't feel like it's helping okay you
guys are going to kill me what's the
name of the girl who sings the driver's
license song
olivia rodriguez okay i'll turn it over
to you olivia did her going to the white
house and talking about the vaccine have
any impact do you think
yes yeah yes it's important to have
conversations with friends and family
members
encouraging all communities to get
vaccinated i saw thousands of thousands
of people on tick tock posting about it
posts they hope will fight vaccine
resistance
a lot of people of color especially are
really hesitant to get the vaccine
and those communities are getting sorry
it's okay
sorry that's okay that's okay
okay all right
that community has like been through so
much
already yeah
and now like with covid they're dying
even worse
getting hospitalized and like there's a
solution
there's a hope here in the philadelphia
school district
vaccines are recommended but not
required how do you feel about that
i think that most kids won't get it
because they feel like it's not
cool they feel like they're tougher than
the vaccine
so you're not just trying to convince
people your age to get vaccinated you're
trying to make the vaccine
cool so to speak i wouldn't say we're
trying to convince people
we're more on educating them because at
the end of the day it's their choice
you provide the facts
for cbs this morning adriana diaz
philadelphia
what a powerful story i know from the
mouth of children i mean they are
leading the way and when you see how
it's affected that young
lady how she feels about it and the
solution is out there that's what
they're saying like
we don't understand what adults are
doing here's the solution yeah
i like adriana's mama bear movement i
know i know
that's great it is amazing though that
what speaks to you
is your peer group and as they said they
weren't listening to the experts but
when you see your peer
sometimes that makes a difference and
you hear from them that olivia rodrigo
going to the white house
that was a big big move because it got a
lot of young people thinking about it
and doing the right thing i love when
kids are smarter than we are just
because you saw it on social media
doesn't mean it's true
oh my gosh there's so much out there
akiva goldsman the writer and director
of i'm legend tweeted oh my god i made
it up
about the zombie memes that are out
there around this thing and that's
problem that's